los angeles times festival of books
visit their website at latimes.com
festival of books
david mccullough's truman won the 1993
pulitzer prize for biography this book
notes interview from 1992 is an hour
david mccullough in your last chapter
called citizen truman you start off by
saying for as
far back nearly as he could remember
truman had held to the ideal of the
mythical roman hero cincinnatus
what's that all about
well cincinnatus was the mythical
hero who left the plow left the farm to
go to
the aid of his country in time of war
and became a great general and
it was victorious and then he renounced
all of his power
and returned to the farm
and that's a theme that this country was
founded on if you go up to
the rotunda in the capital and you look
at the great painting of
by trumbull of george washington turning
over his powers as commander-in-chief of
the continental army to the to the
congress the cincinnati symbols are all
through that painting because the
founding fathers really believed that
this was what democracy
entailed it meant that citizenship meant
that any citizen should be called could
be called upon at any time to serve his
country or her country in any capacity
including the greatest power and that
power belonged to the people therefore
power would be returned by the
the those who held it
for a time
truman like to say uh i tried never to
forget who i was
where i came from and where i would go
back to
now that that is the cincinnati's theme
obviously but it also shows that he
knows who he was he knew who he was and
he was proud of who he was
and uh the return
to independence after he left the office
of the presidency in 1953
was
his way of
letting his actions speak louder than
his words but when he got home
he found that it was
that living up to the idea wasn't as
easy as he expected
and while we all
remember i think with
affection
the the harry truman of independence
missouri walking the same streets of the
town he'd grown up in
and just being citizen truman neighbor
truman once again it wasn't it wasn't
all that easy for him he missed
washington he missed the stimulation and
the pressure and the excitement of of
washington
but
in order to understand truman you have
to understand it seems to me
life in jackson county he lived nearly
70 years of his life in jackson county
missouri he lived to be almost 90 and
spent 20 years in washington as a
senator and vice president eventually
president the year that he left
washington again to go back to
independence 1953 when eisenhower took
the oath of office as the 34th president
of the united states
and when eisenhower took the oath and
when truman walked down off the platform
he was he was right back down on ground
level again as citizen truman he had no
pension
he had no allowance for office space no
franking privileges
no secret service guards
his only income was his army pension
which was i think 119 dollars a month
he got on the train and the president
eisen the new president general
eisenhower had
given him
loaned him the
presidential
parlor car the railroad car that
had belonged to franklin roosevelt the
famous magellan
to ride home to independence
and all the way across the country uh he
was greeted at one town after another by
crowds that came down to the station to
see him
but he got restless and he got up and
walked around that train was just
regular passenger train you know the
rest of the train was full of regular
passengers he just walked up and down
the train saying hello to everybody and
and uh returning to what he had been
his la the last part of his life in many
ways is uh
as is as fulfilling and as happy and as
interesting a part of his life as as all
the rest of it he's a great story is
harry truman i
i'm asked sometimes why did you do
truman and what drew you to truman and
there are many obvious reasons but one
of them certainly is as for me as a
writer is just a wonderful story and the
story of his retirement years
uh is as appealing it was as appealing
for me to write as almost anything in
the book
1117 pages including source notes yeah
correct
if you stop at source notes it gets
992 pages of text a mere slim volume
uh the big the big problem was to keep
it
keep it to one volume i i was determined
that it would not be a two volume
biography i wanted it all in one volume
and i wanted it to be a big book i
didn't know it was going to wind up
quite as big as it is but it's a big big
subject it's a big life and the span the
arc of his life is really
um
it's a chronicle of american life in
those years he goes from
what is essentially a jeffersonian
jacksonian agrarian america of farms and
small towns which he experiences
directly as a boy growing up in a small
town and as a farmer for 11 some years
to
a country that nation that bestrides the
world
with power
based primarily on industrial
technological and scientific
accomplishment
so he he is a he's a 19th century man
formed
in all
manner of
speech habit thought
taste everything formed in that period
before the first world war
and yet he has to face the momentous the
most momentous of all decisions of the
20th century for which theoretically
he's not prepared but then we weren't
prepared as a country either he
to me he's a he's a he's like bunyan's
pilgrim in pilgrim's progress he
he has these various
ordeals and complications and
and difficulties that he has to to
overcome or get beyond each one of which
represents something that
to me symbolizes the history of our
country it's a book this is a book about
america for me
i wanted it to be as much a book about
america as about harry truman there's a
lot of things we can do with this book
and we only have a short hour and i'm
going to just so you'll know i'm going
to stick with the last chapter and also
some of your notes here so that we can i
can help myself from not going all over
the place but in this last chapter
because it's relevant to today you talk
about
that harry truman and his wife
got in their own car
after he was president drove by
themselves back to this town into new
york talk about that well he had a new
chrysler and he loved to drive an
automobile
which is interesting because it was one
of the few recreations he had he didn't
know how to play any sports he didn't
play golf he didn't play tennis
he didn't even he didn't know how to
dance
and so driving an automobile and reading
and walking were his primary
uh recreations
and he bought a new chrysler
and as he said he wanted to give it a
workout
so he and best decided that they would
drive from independence back to
washington
and friends tried to dissuade them from
doing that
but they were determined and they set
off in the car
and it was an adventure in itself
because every town they came to people
of course recognized them it'd be great
fuss and the police would get very
concerned that they were in town and
were worried about their safety and
worried if something happened to them it
would be the fault of the local police
so they would they would literally usher
them out of town as rapidly as possible
best mr truman liked to drive
quite fast uh above the speed limit and
bess didn't approve of that mrs truman
didn't approve of that
so she would have him hold to the speed
limit well as a consequence he they were
often being passed
and when people would pass them by
they'd look in the car and of course
there was
former president united states and his
wife driving along the highway and then
the cars would drop back and pass them
again just to see if their eyes were
playing tricks on them
and truman turned to her and he said
there goes our incognito
and then when they arrived in washington
all the many of the press corps who had
covered him
drove out to maryland to pick him up
they heard that he was coming and waited
for the car to come in and then they all
followed him in into town and he loved
that
and when he stopped at the mayflower and
got out to just his
shirt sleeves on driving the car
the crowd all gathered around traffic
backed up but it caused quite a
commotion
they then drove up to new york to see
margaret who was then living in new york
and went to some shows
went to see
on the town of the leonard bernstein
show
and
went to restaurants just like anybody
visiting new york and again
causing great commotion taxi cabs would
pull over the curb and drivers would
jump out and say hi harry and you're my
man and all that
and then on the way back on the
pennsylvania turnpike a
state trooper pulled him over for
apparently he'd been cutting people too
close when he passed them
he said that the trooper just wanted to
to say hello to him and get his uh shake
his hand but
that was the last automobile trip they
attempted from then on they would go by
train or plane or by boat
when they went to europe
he had been there been an attempted
assassination and a number of presidents
had already been assassinated why
wouldn't the government at that time
have protection for him
just wasn't done why wouldn't the
government have a pension their pension
for army officers and pensions for
everybody else but no pension for
president and he in fact he had very
little money he had to borrow some money
quite
secretly
which dean atchison co-signed
to pay for the move back home
this is not well known and it doesn't
mean that he didn't have any money he
did have money but he needed some cash
to cover all the expenses of moving out
of the white house
and when he got home in order to to
provide himself some income he undertook
the writing of his autobiography his
memoirs which no other president had
ever done except for herbert hoover but
hoover's time in office was much briefer
than was truman's and truman's
presidency covered
far more tumultuous history than
hoover's had so that
to undertake that that two-volume uh
memoir was it was a very major uh
ambitious task
and then he and then he built his
library
now there had been a previous
presidential library franklin
roosevelt's library at hyde park but it
was established after roosevelt died in
office so truman was the first president
to actually officiate over the
establishment of his presidential
library and there again he was he was
beginning something new i think one of
the things i've tried to
to
imply
or to to
emphasize in the book
is that truman was at heart a very
creative
public figure he was a creative
president his was a creative presidency
he'd been a builder all of his life he'd
built roads he'd built courthouses when
he got to washington when he became
president he built the famous truman
balcony on the back of the white house
which caused a great flurry of criticism
and then of course he is the one who
re-entirely rebuilt the white house the
white house we have today
is really the house that harry built
except for the outer shell which was
maintained of the original outer shell
the entire interior is is a
reconstruction of the original house
and he took part in every detail of that
reconstruction he loved it he loved
building he loved creating and things
and
and and in his in of course in a larger
way his presidency
is marked by such creative
uh and innovative uh acts as the
marshall plan and truman doctrine and
nato and point four and so forth so to
to build it to be to again be a builder
in this last uh chapter of his life
uh appealed to him tremendously and the
and the library building the library uh
having his office at the library
welcoming guests there taking people
around the library became his life
except for his travels when he went to
europe and
did did you ever meet him
no i saw him once when i was just a
youngster
on my first job in new york i
i was very starry-eyed i'd gotten a job
in a new magazine called sports
illustrated
and i was coming home from work one
night
we lived over in brooklyn and i came out
of the subway stop at the old st george
hotel
and a big car pulled up there was a
small crowd waiting and i stood with the
crowd and the big car pulled up and
governor harriman stepped out
and i'd never seen a governor before so
i was quite excited about that and then
outstepped
president truman former president truman
and i was just astonished and
and i remember thinking my god he's in
color
because we only have black and white
television black and white newspapers
uh
and i think that the the fact that he
had very high color he radiated good
health um made him seem
very not just vital but a but a person
and
he certainly didn't seem like a little
man to me to to me that moment he was
six foot eight you know
uh but i never i never spoke to him i
never
never met him
i've often thought wouldn't be
interesting if you could go back in time
and i could be able to reach out and
touch him on the shoulder in 1956 that
fall night and say mr president
i'm going to write your biography
someday
but
knowing what you know about him what do
you think he'd think of this
well i'm sure there's some of it he
wouldn't like because
this is after all
an honest attempt to see the complete
man with his flaws and faults too
i but i would hope that in
in some he would think i had understood
him better than other people have i
think that he
he was a much much more
complicated complex
keenly intelligent and
thoughtful considerate man than the
stereotype harry truman
portrait implies
he isn't james whitmore
playing give him hell harry he isn't a
kind of just he isn't just a kind of
salty down home
missouri will rogers
and all of the people that i've
interviewed who knew him and worked with
him and and were in the white house with
him all
say
please understand
that this man was much more than met the
eye
how many interviews did you do
well about 126
and uh that ranged across a broad
spectrum some people who who hardly knew
him at all but saw him come and go as
neighbors or people in
independence
but uh
some and also some of whom who were so
important that i interviewed them many
times over during the ten years that it
took me to write the book who did you
spend the most time with
i would guess in total perhaps either
margaret truman his daughter or george
elsie who was on the white house staff
and clark clifford
and some of the secret service people
who were invaluable because they were
with him all the time
and so many of whom had never been
interviewed before
about him are secret service allowed to
talk after the fact
apparently so
uh if i know we're i mean
and they're wonderful because
they saw him off stage
uh they saw him in all under all
conditions
and often under enormous pressure
tension for exa you mentioned the
attempted assassination
uh two of the secret service men who are
still here in washington
walked me through the whole
event from both inside and outside blair
house where it took place
spent a better part of one saturday
doing that and i don't think
i'm sure that's never been done before
so that my account of that is based on
material
that can only be had by reaching that
time through living people
and their uh their devotion to harry
truman is uh
is a very compelling thing to listen to
and it's true of all the people that
work for him at all levels
i did not find a single person who knew
him well worked with him
who wanted to tell me what his terrible
backstage temper was or what a
what an ungrateful or
difficult boss he was to work with
the closer people were to him the more
not it was just they liked him that they
were devoted to him and uh in a way i
kept hoping i would find some people who
really didn't like him and who had some
uh
skeletons to pull out of the closet but
that that never happened when did you
start all this 10 years ago 1982.
what was the reason
well i was
i was
looking for a subject i'd started
working on a book about pablo picasso i
had i had to go around the barn with
pablo picasso to wind up with harry
truman
and i quit that book i stopped after a
few months because i found i disliked
him so he was to me a
repellent
human being
and he didn't really have a story of the
kind that interested me
he was instantly successful he never
really went very
far
or had any adventures so to speak he was
an immensely important painter he was
the
krakatoa of modern art
but
i found his treatment of his family his
attitude toward women all
he wasn't somebody i wanted to spend
five years with as a roommate so to
speak
and my editor at simon schuster
suggested that i think about doing
franklin roosevelt because at that time
there was not a good one-volume
biography of franklin roosevelt
and just uh on impulse just in a
visceral
way i said no i
if i were going to do a 20th century
president it wouldn't be franklin
roosevelt it would be harry truman and
he said well
why not harry truman so i i looked into
it and i found that there was not a good
biography of harry truman there isn't a
complete
life and times this last chapter that
you are talking about that part of his
life has never been written about before
and it
comprises 20 years of his life very
important part of his life
and
beyond that there was this immense
collection of letters and diaries which
he
she he poured himself out on paper all
of his life and he left
he left a written personal very
revealing record unlike that of any
president that i know of and i'm sure
we're never going to have another
president that
that leaves anything like that we don't
write letters much anymore and we don't
keep diaries much anymore
and he did both his whole life and long
before he ever realized that he was
going to be a figure in history
in one month to give an example in one
month in 1947 when he was president and
when his wife bess was back in
in independence looking after her mother
harry truman the president of the united
states wrote to her 37 times
and these weren't just simple how are
you and the weather's turned cool or
whatever these were these were real
letters did you ever find out how you
wrote them were they long hands they're
all in long hair oh yes the actual
letters all survived yes he had
wonderful clear
straightforward uh strong handwriting
just like he was as if
but
fortunately very legible so that there
never there's never a problem reading
his handwriting
as there was very seldom ever a problem
understanding what he was talking about
in the last chapter you also point out
at some point in his life that he and
his wife best truman called their
daughter margaret every night yes in new
york yes
they were very very close the same
people that were with him as secret
service agents or
or as white house staff domestic staff
in the in the mansion have said that
they were much by far the closest family
that they have ever known in the white
house
and
though they don't want to be quoted
by person they all say that truman was
their favorite president he was the
first president ever to walk out to the
kitchen
first present in their memory to walk
out to the kitchen
to thank the chef or the cook for the
for the dinner that night they think
they remembered calvin coolidge coming
out once or twice but they thought that
was perhaps to see if anybody was
filching food
truman knew everybody by name on the
staff knew all about their families
he had then this wasn't sort of a
politician's device
it's just the way he was
and
the whole give him hell harry harry
truman
on the job at the office in the white
house with his
people at the lowest level or the
highest level never gave anyone hell
he never raised his voice
if anything he's remembered for being
how for how considerate he was
and for small uh favors and courtesies
he would do
let me ask you a few things about
yourself and then we'll get back to
president truman where were you born
i was born in pittsburgh pennsylvania in
1933 i'm the third of
four sons my family have
lived in pittsburgh for many many
generations
and i grew up
i grew up in a very happy household my
my own children have told me you have no
chance of ever being a serious writer
pop because you had too happy a
childhood
what did your parents do well my father
had an electrical supply business
mccullough electric company which
is still in business my one of my
brothers now runs it
and
i went to yale uh university and when i
got out of yale i was
determined to go down to new york and
get a job either in a magazine or a
newspaper
how did you get into yale
well i guess i just did well enough on
the college board exams and i had pretty
good grades in high school and uh
my two older brothers had gone there and
that seemed to help in those days what'd
you study i was an english major
and a minor in art fine arts i was torn
whether i wanted to be a writer or a
painter
i never imagined that i would be wind up
writing history and biography but
i feel that in my work that i'm
i'm working in a school following in a
tradition or a school of other
writers who have not been trained
academically as as historians but who
are writers who
work in the past the way a
foreign correspondent might work in
another country
people like
barbara tuchman and bruce catton and
paul horgan and wallace stegner
and robert carroll and robert massey
lots lots of them i suppose we're we're
lapsed journalists he came to new york
for what reason after school to find a
job i
pounded the streets i tried to get a job
on the new york herald tribune and
collier's magazine and
time life
was hired part of time life to be a
trainee at sports illustrated how long
did you stay there well i stayed at time
life for five and five almost five and a
half years and then when john kennedy
was elected i came down to washington to
be part of the
new frontier a very lowly member i
worked at the u.s information agency
when ed murrow was running it which was
very exciting and wonderful and but
after the president was killed and after
mero was ill and leaving his post i
went back to new york to work for uh as
an editor and writer at american
heritage magazine
american heritage publishing company
and my major effort there was the
picture history of world war ii
which is still in print
below these many years and then i at
that point i started writing my first
book which on night at night and on
weekends which was the johnstown flood
published in 1968. how many other books
this is my sixth book
during this 10-year period from 1982 to
1992 did you write any other books or
was this well i published a collection
and anthology of essays which came out
last year called brave companions
but no no other books but i did a good
deal on television
i've been the host of the smithsonian
world series on public television and
and lately in the last five years for
the
american experience series
and i've narrated a number of other
documentaries like the lbj
program and the civil war what was that
the voice uh you can hear that voice
over 11 episodes of the civil war did
you get much reaction from people around
the country well yes i do often if i'm
at an airline
ticket counter or i order something in a
restaurant somebody's head will snap
around and say the civil war
that was a big a big undertaking and
it's almost wall-to-wall narration so i
felt like i've been in the game all 60
minutes but it was never seen
but it's it's a it was a privilege to to
be part of that series it's a wonderful
project and ken burns is
is
a major
figure in broadcasting today because any
and he defied all the experts he
you know
the conventional wisdom about television
was that nobody was interested in
serious programming documentary program
and certainly nobody would watch
anything that went on for that many
hours how much time did you devote to
that
well i was involved with it from the
beginning and as i recall it took about
four and a half years i think it
actually wound up taking a little longer
than it took to fight the war
in the notes in the back the
acknowledgements
you
talk a lot about your family and
rather than me read it
how many kids and how many of them were
involved in this thing well we have five
children and they all helped in one way
or another uh some uh extensively uh one
son drove me all through france to
follow the whole war uh harry truman's
part in world war one and that same
young fellow took the photograph of me
on the back of the the back of the book
that's bill mccullough
and jeffrey mccullough who is another
son helped with research on capitol hill
at the library of congress others helped
with
either research or
are sustaining their father through
difficult times and the book is
dedicated to our youngest daughter um
dory mccullough who
who did a
very valuable work
helping with the research on the
restoration of the white house but more
than that who was who was with us
all the time with my wife and me all the
time through those ten years
we moved to washington to do the
smithsonian series
when i was 50 years old which is exactly
the time that truman came to washington
as a senator and we came with one
daughter who was a a teenager just as
margaret was then and we lived in a very
small apartment and we're making all the
adjustments one does
to living in washington so there was a i
felt a certain empathy when writing
about truman
uh in in his senatorial years
from firsthand experience and i think
was very valuable for me in writing the
book to have been here because
i
you know they talk about the
paleontologists
in order to better understand the fossil
record study the the living form well in
studying the
historical record about the senate
and the when the white house and the
whole way that the bureaucracy works and
uh and the press works everything about
washington
it helped to study the living form as
well as the historical record you say
that uh with senate historian dick baker
uh you ran
one night uh what right after roosevelt
well yes uh the there's the one of the
one of the most dramatic moments in the
in the whole story is when truman uh
then the the evening of roosevelt's
death is is summoned uh from the white
house by the press secretary steve early
when truman was having a drink with sam
rayburn in what was
euphemistically known as the board of
education it was uh
rayburn's hideaway beneath the uh
the house uh uh side uh where they would
meet for a drink after work every day
and truman on getting the message from
early that he was to come at once
to the white house
left rayburn's office and ran back
to
his own office his vice president's
office on the senate side
and i wanted to make that run for one
thing i wanted to to do it in order to
find out what time he must have been at
various places i knew how fast he walked
so i could tell how long it took him to
walk over and i timed the walk from from
the vice president's office over to
rayburn's hideaway
but you can't just start running through
the through the capitol so i called dick
baker and i asked him if he could
arrange for me to make the run at the
same time
and he said oh i know why you want to do
that he said yes i'll arrange it but
only under the condition that i can run
with you
so with two white house two uh capital
police as our escorts we made the run
and we were coming along through the
hall and if you run through
those stone halls of the capitol with
four men with the street shoes on
it's it's a thunderous sound
and uh we came up to a point where the
where the white house or the where the
capitol police have there have kind of a
rest area and an office
and they heard this noise and that four
or five of them came
came out into the hall to see what was
going on and they looked up the hall and
of course what they saw
was one capitol policeman running in the
running straight for them
seemingly being chased by two guys in
suits civilian suits with another
capital policeman chasing from behind
and they the capitol police as we could
see
looked very apprehensive as we came
charging
toward them
and as we got up to them
the
capitol
officer who was out in front said to
them don't ask
you know i never could possibly explain
to you what we're doing don't ask anyway
we did make the run it was a long run it
was very worthwhile
it's an interesting point because
truman said later that he did not think
it didn't occur to him that the
president was dead
he thought that the president had come
back from warm springs secretly
and wanted to confer with him about
something
but if he didn't think that the
president was dead why was he running
and if he didn't know the president was
dead why what did he think he was
running toward and what was he what was
he running away from it's just
if it were a movie if it were a film you
could almost see that a freeze frame on
that moment where he's
where he's running down the hall and
he's and of course by then he's he's
president of the united states
and he's with he's running alone he has
no capital guards or
dick baker running with him he's running
alone
and
it must have been if if he knew and he
had to have known if he wasn't even
admitting it to himself he had to have
known subconsciously it must have been a
dreadful time for him and then he
arrives at he arrives at the white house
goes up to the family quarters and he
steps off the elevator
and mrs roosevelt comes forward and puts
her arm
her hand on his arm and says to him very
qui softly uh
harry the president is dead
and i i i feel that that's a
very revealing moment about harry truman
because when you think of how he might
have responded
and at first he couldn't say anything
but when he did was able to speak he
said to her is there anything i can do
for you
and then of course she says to him no
harry
is there anything we can do for you
you're the one in trouble now
and he
he is a
he is a character on an odyssey who who
was in trouble of one kind or another
much of his life
in thrust into jobs that he doesn't seem
up to but then he has to rise to the
occasion whether it's to
run the family farm when his father dies
or whether it's to be a
an officer of a of a artillery battery
in
in world war
one
or whether it's to be a senator uh
emerging from the
the shadow the stigma of of his
pendergast uh organization background
he always has to get out of the hole so
to speak but this is the this is the
biggest hole he's ever in when he's
suddenly present because roosevelt
franklin roosevelt had told him nothing
now most people know that he had been
told nothing by the president about the
atomic bomb but that was only part of it
he was told nothing about anything by
roosevelt
which was not only in my view
irresponsible on roosevelt's part but
but unkind
so when
when mrs roosevelt says you're the one
that's in trouble now she she knew what
she was talking about
you write a lot about the selection
process for the vice president for the
1944 elections yes and you also
mentioned a number of times how the
people around roosevelt president
roosevelt knew he was and he was sick
very sick man and and it was commonly
known at the convention so when they all
convened in chicago in 1944 i think it's
one of the most dramatic stories in
american political history
they know
that their nominee for the presidency
franklin roosevelt is running for his
fourth term isn't going to survive isn't
going to last very long he's a dying man
but this is kept secret it's a it's a
cover-up as we would say but for very
good reason we were at war
and it was
absolutely essential that
neither our allies nor say at least the
enemy
get the idea that this most powerful of
all nations powerful among the allied
nations is being led by a dying man
but they know therefore that the vice
presidency is worth
is worth everything it's they're
nominating two presidents
and the irony of the of the story is
that the man they nominate
in the end truman doesn't want to be
nominated
whereas the other two henry wallace and
jimmy burns are exceedingly ambitious
and want it very much who was the vice
president and henry wallace was the vice
president and
roosevelt was playing a very uh uh
sort of tricky manipulative game because
he told both
wallace
and burns you're my man you go to in
effect you you go to chicago and you'll
get the nomination you were that you're
the man i want
but it was the political bosses
who wanted truman one of the
misconceptions about truman is that he
was an accidental president he wasn't
accidental at all
because the political bosses the
big powers in the democratic party
didn't want wallace because they felt he
was too left-wing
and too eccentric and they didn't want
jimmy burns who had been a
famous senator from south carolina as
well as a supreme court judge and one of
roosevelt's most important assistants at
the white house they didn't want him
because he was too conservative and an
avowed segregationist
they wanted truman
and roosevelt finally under tremendous
pressure from them agreed okay but it'll
be truman and at one point he says i
hardly know truman
so
it was very much
truman is very much the creation of the
smoke-filled room
of the old boss system
and one can't help but feel therefore
that the smoke-filled room wasn't an
entirely bad way to go about the
business
of picking
presidents and vice presidents and that
the bosses knew what they were doing
because we were
extremely fortunate as a nation
that harry truman was there to replace
franklin roosevelt in 1945
because even though he had not been told
much and even though on paper
you know by a conventional resume his
background would seem to be
inadequate for the presidency
he had in many ways been superbly
prepared for the presidency because of
his life experience he had been through
what so much of the country had been
through he knew from first-hand personal
experience so much of what american life
was about then
in your last chapter you talked a lot
about him surviving that period
financially and that the memoirs were
worth about hundred thousand dollars to
him in advance
yes but by the time he paid all of his
taxes and uh the rest he'd wound up with
not very much what finally saved him
financially and again it's it's one of
these great circles
of the story is the old family farm out
of grandview which was sold
to make way for a shopping center and
suburban sprawl
and it would turned out to be very
valuable well he'd been raised on
the old jeffersonian
idea that land was what mattered and and
in the long run it was the value of land
that would see you through the hardest
of times and the family had hung onto
that farm through terrible times through
all kinds of depression and drought and
all the rest because they felt this
this was what had real value and in the
in the final analysis
it wasn't his political career it wasn't
uh his fame it wasn't his
memoirs
all the other things that one would
assume would
give him security but that land
uh
when i think about his years and i think
about your 10 years in getting this
together i want to ask you the same
question how do you survive financially
during this period
well i do a lot of lecturing
and uh my
publisher gave me an advance which is
you know is the way it works and
television
now what makes what will make this book
a success
well
i don't know what how to how to answer
that as far as i'm concerned what makes
it a success is is it reaches readers uh
it's already
a bestseller it became rapidly a
bestseller within a matter of weeks and
for a
922-page serious biography to go right
to the top of the bestseller list
in the summertime
is it i won't say it's unprecedented but
it's certainly rare
and
i think that in part
that is because
truman still has a very high
standing great appeal
among all of us
but i think too that in this political
year he represents something that the
country
more than in other years perhaps
wants to reach out for
an authenticity
a
clarity a
lack of artifice
in his personal and his presidential
manner
truman stood for something he always
stood for something
you might not have agreed with with his
position but you knew where he stood was
he was he loyal to his wife
he certainly was absolutely no funny
stuff never never never
in fact there's a scene with potsdam
where
he gets into his car and
to drive back to his quarters
and a
army officer
puts his head in the window of the car
and
late at night and tells him mr president
i can arrange anything you'd like while
you're here uh
anything in the way of wine or
and he says and and women
and truman is absolutely
livid tonight can i read that i happen
to have that underline when i read it i
wanted to ask you about that
listen son i married my sweetheart
truman said
she doesn't run around on me and i don't
run around on her and i want that
understood don't ever mention that kind
of stuff to me again
by the time we were home boring
remembered and that was the
secret service man the secret service
man he got out of the car and never even
said goodbye to that guy now what and
what in the world would a
officer ever be doing saying this to a
president
who knows
almost unimaginable he was offering to
be a procurer for him did you find this
out strictly from that secret service
man yes that's never been published no
um
many of the secret service people that i
interviewed have never been interviewed
before i spent one long night with uh
jim rowley who was the head of the
secret service detail at the end of the
evening i thanked him for
giving me three or four hours of his
time
here's a man who he hadn't just been
with truman he'd been with roosevelt
he'd been with churchill stalin
and i said thank you and i want to
particularly thank you when i think of
how often you must have been asked these
questions he said mr mccullough i've
never been asked these questions
uh truman's affection his devotion to
bess is a very
major part of his life and a very
it's it's a very touching aspect of the
story and it's entirely true
the the reason we have all these letters
is because he was so devoted to her his
courtship of her is just one of the
great stories
that i know of of sort of
pre-world war one middle america this
young fellow out in the farm who's in
love with the
daughter of a prominent
by the terms of independence well-to-do
family
it's an uphill struggle the family does
not want her to marry him
it's his first campaign
and he pursues her he doesn't let defeat
discourage him he's cheerful he's
he's
he's devote
he's loyal to her
he seems always to want to please her
in the letters
he seems to be asking her always how am
i measuring up
he shared
i noticed throughout your book a lot of
insider information when he was in
potsdam in places oh yes
and with his mother and his sister
imagine the president united states
sitting down every night writing dear
mama and mary jane from uh from potsdam
where he's meeting with churchill and
stalin for the first time he's never
been on
the world stage before and let alone on
the world stage with such figures as
churchill and stalin
and he had no
he had no
small experience with stage fright he
but he quitted himself very well at
potsdam i some several of the people who
were with him thought he did better
overall than roosevelt would have done
you write
page 949
by the way what's this thing cost 30
bucks yes
except at discount stores where you can
save yeah 10 bucks in the winter time
you can put it in your trunk and
wait down the back of your car an icy
day by the way do you have any
perception i mean perception you have
any projections at all as to how many of
these are going to sell
well no but it's uh it's
you know it's well copies are out there
now 200 over 200 000 is it a book of the
month club oh yeah it's the book of the
month club selection it's
number one bestseller as we talk at
least in washington number three on the
new york times list i mean it's just
unheard of that this would happen to
a book of this kind
you know this is this is the season of
light beach reading supposedly but i
think that i really feel that
that the book is
is designed it was written specifically
as
as
a return to an america
that was
hours not so long ago
not
out of nostalgia
but because this was real
and this is where this is who we are and
we must be reminded of who we are
we must be reminded of the tough
times we've been through a wonderful
line of churchills we didn't come this
far because we're made of sugar candy
when you see
what he as an individual and what we as
a country have accomplished what we've
built what we've stood for
and i think that uh
if he reminds us of anything it's it's
the is it's the strength and the
vitality
and the common sense
of the democratic
process lowercase d when you travel
around you appear on the talk shows and
call-in shows and all that what are the
things that people ask you the most
about this book
well at the moment
it's uh about ross perot
and the question
is often
doesn't ross perot reminds you of harry
truman
and what interests me about that
question is the is the underlying wish
that that i will say yes
they want
me to say yes ross perot is another
harry truman because i see i feel that
we
we
miss we are
hungry for the kind of authenticity that
truman represented
we're we're
we've had it with what truman would have
called the hui of politics
the the
the creation of
candidates and
personality persona by
ghost writers spin doctors
madison avenue
experts and so forth when truman went
out in 48 which in many ways is the
is the ultimate expression of his of
what he represents and campaigned across
the country in the so-called whistle
stop campaign stopping the train all the
little towns along the way
for 22 000 miles
brutal
shattering physically shattering
experience for lots of people who were
on the train with him who were still
alive and remember it vividly
he spoke to the people directly
he spoke spontaneously
he spoke
in complete sentences
and uh i think his
latin teachers would have been very
proud of
proud of him you read those speeches
today and you think is wouldn't it be
wonderful
wouldn't it be
wouldn't it be reassuring if somebody
were as direct with us as that man
was every day five six 15 times a day at
these little stops
talking about problems talking about
solutions talking about where he stood
and never never whining
never blaming other people
never blaming his star so to speak
and
dogged dogged determination
and the conviction that he was going to
win which was shared by nobody
none of the experts none of the
pollsters none of the professional
politicians thought he had a chance
in the last chapter of you uh i was
starting to ask about page 949 i'm going
to jump to another thing because we're
running out of time you uh write a lot
about
near the end of his life they're trying
to reconcile with general eisenhower um
and there's one incident where you say
they spent an hour together in a room
near the end what was that about do you
remember
yes he both general eisenhower and
president former president truman came
to
washington for john kennedy's funeral
and they spent an hour together at blair
house and they
they made up they reconciled their
differences and was that was that
meeting that what actually went on
between the two of them for that ever
written anywhere
it's not known exactly what was said but
it's been written about before but not
the way it is here i think that
uh it's important to understand that
truman made up with everybody that he'd
ever had a fight with he uh
he was a very forgiving person his his
temper was
hot
but it blew over fairly fast with a few
exceptions but the only person he never
had a reconciliation with was general
macarthur
but even there he did send macarthur's
birthday greetings on occasion but where
they went unanswered but he made up with
president nixon he made up with
paul hume the music critic for the
washington post who hadn't liked
margaret his
truman singing he made he's still alive
by the way paul hume yes he made it
no because he's i gather he's writing a
book about uh about that all
all that experience himself
so
he was not willing to talk one other
instant
that was interesting was when
president truman was writing in the car
with general eisenhower
and
i don't remember you can remember who
was there blurted out to general
eisenhower and he was president at the
time uh you can be president uh i mean
i'd support you as president yes he
tried he tried twice to get eisenhower
to run for the presidency
as a democrat yes
according to one account he even offered
to uh run in 1948 as the vice
presidential candidate if eisenhower
would agree to run as president imagine
that
so when they had their breakup
it was it was very painful to truman
because he had so admired eisenhower
and that the breakup came because
eisenhower refused to repudiate
joe mccarthy senator joe mccarthy when
mccarthy
attacked general marshall
and called him a traitor
and truman thought
thought the world of marshall truman
thought that marshall was the greatest
man of the 20th century
and truman knew as everyone knew that
marshall was the one who had made
eisenhower
who had elevated him to the position
that he held in world war ii
and for eisenhower to sit on the same
platform with mccarthy and not include a
paragraph that was in the prepared
speech
which repudiated mccarthy's charges was
to truman
a moment of rank betrayal and he really
almost never got over it but eventually
did
books
all through your book you write many
times about harry truman being
surrounded by books he was a reader he
was a lifelong reader i asked margaret
one day
what would be your father's idea of
heaven
and she said oh that's easy she said it
would be a a good comfortable armchair
and a good reading lamp
and a stack of new history and biography
that he wanted to read
he once said that all
readers
can't be leaders but all leaders must be
readers and particularly history and
biography and his sense of history is
one of the crucial
aspects of him as a president because
what it meant was that he he knew that
what mattered in the long run was the
judgment of history the judgment of the
country in the long run so that he could
ride out the sinking polls or the or the
calls for his impeachment say when he
fired general macarthur he could ride
that out with amazing equilibrium
i think because he knew that what
mattered was the judgment in the long
run and he knew that in the long run he
would be judged to have done the right
thing to have upheld civilian control of
the military books and walking and then
something that didn't track that he
liked a couple of jolts of bourbon in
the morning yes that was if there was
one startling discovery i made
that he he had a pop
in the morning
well apparently quite early and
apparently it was his way of getting the
engine going he he would go for his walk
which was a good vigorous two mile fast
walk or more than two miles come back
and do some setting up exercises and
have a rub down and then have a drink
and when i was first told this by the
assistant
head usher jb west
i thought well no no this that couldn't
be but
it was confirmed by two or three other
accounts as well what was he like in
death
he was very
stubborn holding on
long after he
should have died in the hospital and i
think he was sustained by
what was then considered to be
miraculous modern medicine longer than
he should have been
what did he die he was a wonderful he
was a model patient he never complained
well it was a complete breakdown of the
whole system heart lungs intestines
everything how long did his wife best
live after he died
he lived almost 10 more years he died in
what year 1972 just after christmas and
did you have a chance to talk to her at
all no she was unable to see people
do you have another book in mind
well i have several but i haven't made a
decision yet on what what will be next
is there a movie or a series on
television on youtube there will be
at the moment there are two different
television
networks
interested in the book
but it will be it will be a
dramatization of
the book on television after all you saw
of uh harry truman and and learned about
him um
if you were here today would you vote
for him absolutely i would normally vote
for him i'd go out and work hard to see
that he was elected he wasn't perfect
and he he did make mistakes his loyalty
program was a serious mistake
uh and then he made other mistakes but
he
we he reminds us of what a man in that
job can be
and what he can do and
the it wasn't just that he made
decisions he accomplished things he
created
legislation ideas constructive policy
again and again and again
and if it hadn't been for the korean war
which is really what
caused his downfall in in popularity
uh his his standing with the country
would have would have not suffered as it
did by the way as we end uh looking at
this cover who did it
wendell miner who was i think
an immensely gifted man who's done the
book the jackets for all of my books but
won
i think it's a an important portrait
because it it suggests the
the road that truman travels from the
farm to the white house which of course
is
represents the road that the country's
traveled from an agrarian nation to a
world world power
david mccullough author of truman thank
you very much for your time
thank you
david mccullough's truman was awarded
the 1993 pulitzer prize for biography
it's available in paperback from simon
schuster on the web at simonsays.com
next week on encore